Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Jawasch.
Ich bin Diensthabender Ast.
Ich bin heute für Sie zuständig.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Timo Özdemir.
Könnten Sie vornahm- und nachnahm-Hüstebieren?
Ja gerne.
Ich höre Sie ganz schlecht.
Man muss eines Verbindungsjungs sein.
Ansemisch.
Ich höre Sie ganz schlecht.
Man muss eines Verbindungsjuchs sein.
Ansemisch.
Ja, ich höre Ihnen.
Ich heiße Timo Özdemir.
Ich kann es gerne bestimmen.
T-I-M-U-S.
Özdemir.
Wie stand Özdemir,
wie man das lesen kann.
Timo Özdemir.
Genau.
Damit fragen Sie nach Wernseekastikverschtern
Herr Özdemir, ich werde Ihnen gerne ein paar allgemein Angaben stellen,
bevor Sie mich über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Okay, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
50 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
71.
71?
Okay.
Wie viel haben Sie?
80 Kilo.
Okay.
Herr Özdemir, was für Sie ist uns?
Ich habe in der letzten Zeit so trockene Husten.
Trockene Husten?
Genau.
Können Sie gerne beschreiben Ihre Hüste?
Mit Aschfurf oder?
Nein, da hat es sich gesagt, es ist trockene Husten.
Ich habe keinen Auswurf eigentlich.
Sonst hätte ich das anders beschrieben.
Die habe ich seit ungefähr, ja, in den letzten 2 Monaten,
aber jetzt ist es ein bisschen vermehrt.
Am Anfang war es so, ganz normal, leicht.
Und später, beim Belastung, etwas mehr.
Und in den letzten Tagen ist es richtig zu nehmen.
Sie haben Trockene Husten seit 2 Monaten richtig?
Ja, ja, genau.
Mit Belastung, aber letzter Zeit zu nehmen.
Genau.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Brustschmerzen, ja, eigentlich ist es so,
dass, wenn ich mich belassen, natürlich habe ich so ein Druckgefühl auf den Brust.
Aber so ein Dreckbrustschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Ein Druckgefühl im Brust.
Ja, auf den Brust, ja.
Haben Sie andere Beschwerden?
Was meinen Sie mit anderen Beschwerden?
Vielleicht Luftnoten, Atmennoten.
Ja, als ich schnell laufen, manchmal,
ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich mehr Luft brauche
und daher versuche, das mich zu brimsen, langsam zu laufen.
Und zu dem wenig Rauchen,
dann ist es mir auch schlechter, so zu sagen.
Ich könnte gut rauchen, aber jetzt in der letzten Zeit
kann ich auch nicht richtig viel rauchen.
Das schmeckt mich irgendwie nicht so gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie Herzrasen?
Herzrasen, ja, natürlich.
Wenn ich so ein leichter Druckgefühl habe auf den Brust
und wenn ich mich belasse, dann spüre ich schon,
dass das Herz schneller steckt.
Manchmal habe ich dann Herzrasen, die fühlen noch dazu.
Aber als ich gesagt habe, dass es nicht dauerhaft,
das ist nur unter der Belastung.
Daher muss es nur mal sein, ich gehe davon aus.
Haben Sie früher annüche Beschwerden,
vor ein Jahr oder sehr vor sechs Monaten?
Haben Sie annüche Beschwerden?
Eigentlich nicht.
Muss ich ehrlich sein, ich hatte das nie gehabt.
Natürlich, Houston hat man jeder,
das ist nicht das, was ich jetzt sage,
ich habe nie Houston gehabt.
Solange längerer Zeit das Problem habe ich nicht gehabt.
Ich habe gedacht, es geht weg.
Am Anfang so etwas wie Houston-Reise,
später hat sich, so zu sagen, vermehrt und vermehrt,
dass ich jetzt heute bei Ihnen befinde.
Gibt es etwas Verstärkungen in den Hüsten?
Ja, als ich das versteckt habe,
das ist schon, wenn ich mich belaste.
Ländert das nur einfach, wenn ich mich nicht belaste, so ist das.
Schlafen Sie mit Kissen?
Ja, eigentlich, Nacht habe ich gar kein Problem.
Ich schlafe kein Problem.
Ja, im Ruhr habe ich gar kein Problem.
Ich kann gut schlafen.
Im Alltag zu Hause, wenn ich mich langsam bewege,
habe ich auch keine Probleme damit, das geht auch eigenermaßen.
Haben sich die Hüsten im Verlauf der Zeit verändert?
Vielleicht nachtliche Hüsten, Amtag oder Nacht?
Ja, Belastung, ich verstehe, aber andere...
Ja, im Ruhr, natürlich leicht,
so eine Reishusten habe ich schon,
aber die hat sich nicht vermehrt, muss ich sagen.
Etwas schon, aber nicht so ausgeprägt,
dass ich sage, ich kann nicht richtig sitzen,
ich habe keine Ruhe, so ist das nicht.
Aber Alltag ist es schon gestört,
wenn ich meine Alltag durchführen soll,
wenn ich draußen gehe, einkaufen und so weit,
dann ist es mir schon nicht so, wie es war.
Ja, es ist schon schlechter.
Okay, ich verstehe, Herr Rosdemus.
Okay, Herr Rosdemus.
Jetzt, ich werde Ihnen jetzt einige Fragen
für Ihrem Allgemeinen zustande stellen.
Hat sich Ihre Appetit letzter Zeit verändert?
Nein, ich habe in der letzten Zeit etwas schlechter Appetit.
Ja, das kann ich zustimmen.
Aber so stark ist es nicht,
natürlich ist es ein bisschen reduziert,
aber trotzdem nicht stark Gewicht auf die Talle.
Ihr Mikrofon bietet aus.
Ich finde, die Gehörer sind sehr zugehörig.
Ich höre sie.
Ich halte meine Gewichte stabil, muss ich sagen.
Ich habe es schon, aber nicht so stark,
dass ich 10 kg verloren habe.
Seit wann, wie viel Sie, wer Sie seit Jahren verlassen haben?
Nein, ich habe gesagt, ich kann das nicht sagen,
dass ich 10 kg verloren habe.
Ich habe meine Gewichte stabil, fast stabil.
Ich bin 80 kg und das ist auch stabil.
Ich habe keine Gewicht verloren.
Okay, haben Sie verstanden, dass du es bemerkt?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe das Gefühl schon in der letzten Zeit,
vor allem während Belastung.
Wie sieht es mit dem Stuhlgang aus oder Wasser lassen auf?
Ist alles in Ordnung mit Stuhlgang aus Wasser lassen?
Ja, ist in Ordnung.
Damit habe ich gar kein Problem.
Haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, auch nicht.
Wie ist Ihnen das mit dem Stuhlgang aus?
Okay.
Haben Sie Schwindel?
Ja, wenn ich schnell aufstehe, dann schon.
Okay.
Vielleicht, wenn Sie treppen, viele treppen
und Luft noch zu bekommen.
Wichtig?
Noch mal können Sie das wiederholen.
Vielleicht steigen, treppen oder laufen,
langen.
Sie meinen, wenn ich treppe, auch steige
oder treppe, auch laufe, ob ich Luftnot habe?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe auch gesagt, in der letzten Zeit schon.
Unter Belastung habe ich Probleme schon.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Fibbus?
Nein, nicht.
Haben Sie Schwindelfrost oder nach Schweißkart,
Schweiß, Schweiß, Arschbrücke?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Okay, Herr Rosemil, jetzt wir kommen
in Ihrem Krankengeschichte.
Gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen?
Zum Beispiel Herzkrankheiten, Lungenkrankheiten
oder Arterilm, Hypertonie?
Okay, ob ich eine, ob ich eine,
unter einer Grundschrankung leide,
meinen Sie das?
Wer ist die Krankheit?
Ich war bisher kein gesund.
Ich habe nie was gehabt.
Ich nehme fast gar keine Medikamente
an der Sicht regelmäßig.
Und was ich ab und zu einfach einnehme,
ist es so Schmerzmittel,
dass man mal einen Knieschmerzen hat
oder mal weiß nicht genau Bauchschmerzen.
Das kann bei jeder Patientin.
Das würde ich nicht als Probleme vorlegen.
Ab und zu gehen Schmerzen,
Sie nehmen Schmerzmittel einnehmen.
Genau.
Nehmen Sie andere Medikamente? Nein.
Nein.
Okay, Herr Rosemil,
jetzt kommen wir in allergenen,
haben Sie bestimmte allergenigen Pläne
oder Medikamente?
Hausstab?
Es ist mir auch nicht bekannt.
Haben Sie Unwörtheitlichkeiten?
Unverträglichkeiten,
eigentlich auch nicht.
Okay, Herr Thunhoff.
Und jetzt wir kommen in Ihrem Familiengeschichte.
Gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen
mit Familienanhörigen?
Vater, Mutter, Geschwester, Kinder?
Meine Vater, der lebt noch.
Er hat Räume und nimmt natürlich seine Medikamente,
wie es halt empfohlen ist,
oder würden von den Ersten.
Und meine Mutter ist leider schon verstorben.
Die hat Gewirmutterkrebs gehabt.
Und das war schon ein Lastestadium.
Die hat Felseschemotherapie bekommen,
aber hat es nicht geschafft.
Können Sie bitte nochmal Ihre Vaterskrankheit?
Räume.
Sind Sie leben oder gestiegen?
Er lebt noch.
Meine Vater meint sie.
Ja, Ihre Vater, ja.
Er lebt noch.
Er ist 80 Jahre alt.
Okay, 80 Jahre alt.
Okay, und haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe ein Bruder,
der ist auch 45 Jahre alt,
aber der ist kein gesünder,
der hat auch nichts, soweit ich weiß.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, habe ich keine Kinder.
Okay, jetzt kommen wir hier geworden.
Hallo, es ist der Mirz.
Rauchen Sie.
Ja, habe ich gesagt, ich rauche leider.
In der letzten Zeit weniger, aber rauche ich schon.
Wie viele Sekunden rauchen Sie?
Ungefähr 20 Sekunden.
Ich konnte in der letzten Zeit,
zwischen 10 bis 15 Sekunden.
Wie lange sind Sie?
Seit dieser Russengeschichte.
Seit ungefähr 2 Monaten.
Ja, okay.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Seit wie lange?
Ungefähr 30 Jahre.
30 Jahre.
Aber ich bin sehr alt.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke nur einmal pro Tag ein Bier.
Und am Wochenende mit Freunden,
einmal im Monat, so eine Schnaps,
halt so ein weinhaltiger Sache.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie über diese Frage.
Das ist eine routine Frage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Ich habe nie Drogen probiert.
Ja, okay.
Hör uns, was ist Ihr Pompier auf?
Ich arbeite in einer Sicherheitfirma.
Können Sie bitte...
...sich als Transport-Büchleiter.
Ich arbeite in einer Firma.
Ich habe keine Spezialität, muss ich sagen.
In der Firma mache ich ein Putzbereich,
aber ich habe was anderes.
Aber ich bin tätig in einer Firma,
wo die aufsichtig sind,
um eine Flughafensicherheit zu sagen.
Ich habe keine Spezialität,
ich bin angestellt dort.
Ich bin Springer von Arbeit zu Arbeit.
Okay.
Sie ist verarbeitet?
Nein, auch nicht.
Hab es sich im Leben...
...und ich bin ausgebildet.
Ich habe keine Berufsache.
Das stört mich schon.
Das macht mich nervös.
Aber ich kann es nicht ändern.
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
Ich kann etwas lernen.
Ich muss noch mitkämpfen.
Ich bin fertig.
Ich werde jetzt eine Kurse zusammenfasseln machen.
Sie haben seit zwei Monaten
Trockenhüsten und Lesterzeit.
Sie haben diese Beschwerde verschlimmert.
Ja.
Ich bin fertig.
Ich habe diese Beschwerde verschlimmert.
Und mit Belastung dieser Hüsten.
So nehmen wir sie.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch Informationen, die wichtig sind?
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich besuch die Beschwerden.
Eigentlich habe ich alles, was ihr sehen soll.
Ich habe ein trockenes Husten.
Ich habe zwei, drei Mal ein Blut gesehen.
Als ich gesprochen habe.
Aber es ist 90% trocken.
Es ist ein bisschen schleim.
Aber es ist nicht so aufgeprägt.
Ich sage, das stört mich.
Ich gehe davon aus, weil ich dauerhaft trüster bin.
Dadurch verletze ich das Schleim.
Dadurch sammelt es sich ein bisschen schleim.
Dann blutet es.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass ich ohne Blut habe.
Es ist nur leicht Blut in den Sput,
was ich gesehen habe.
Das war ein, zwei Mal.
Ein oder zweimal?
Ja.
Ich habe es nicht so gut geschleimt.
Okay, Herr Rosendemirsch.
Jetzt, Herr Rosendemirsch.
Ich werde Ihnen jetzt Blut für Stabos abnehmen.
Und danach machen wir die Körperlichte und die Rohung.
Und wir machen rundkern Torax.
Und vielleicht sieht ihr Torax.
Wenn sobald alle Befunde vorliegen,
ich komme zu Ihnen und will sprechen, Ihre Station.
Alles klar, weiß ich Bescheid.
Das heißt, ich bleibe es mal hier.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Danke auch.
Nehmen Sie Platz bitte, warte es immer.
Danke schön.
Okay, haben wir was vergessen, um runter zu fragen?
Sind Sie deswegen schon bei einem anderen Arzt gewesen?
Nein, noch.
Das haben Sie letztes Mal in einem Covid-Patienten Kontakt haben?
Ja.
Danke.
Ich sind direkt mit dem Patient nicht,
aber ich bin getestet, ich war negativ auch.
Ich habe mich schnell getestet,
ich war nach Hause gelassen, und das war negativ auch.
Noch?
Noch, bitte.
Haben Sie geschehen,
nur differenzial,
eigentlich nicht.
Gute Frage, aber nein.
Nehmen Sie diese Beschwerden-Medikamente ein?
Ja, habe ich.
Ich habe gedacht, es ist vielleicht eine allergische Reaktion
auf etwas, was ich auch nicht kenne.
Vielleicht bin ich auch immer noch nicht sicher,
ob es ein allergisches Problem ist.
Ich habe nie so etwas gehabt.
Und daher habe ich gesagt,
es geht vielleicht nach einer Weile,
aber leider hat sich das passiert.
Ich habe es nicht gemacht,
welche Fragen ich nicht weiss,
die ich in der Sitzdorf oder der FIP-Hand gebe.
Meinen Sie so eine Luft durch den Husten?
Ja, ja, ja.
Das sind aber bei der Köpfeuntersuchung nach Fragen.
Das ist nicht an Amnesien.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Ich habe es auch nicht gemacht,
aber ich habe auch nicht auf die Köpfeuntersuchung nach Fragen.
Das ist jetzt nicht an Amnesien.
In der FIP-Hand-Atmung?
Nein, aber so etwas habe ich nicht gehabt.
Da habe ich auch gefragt, ob ich eine Luftnot habe.
So eine starke Luftnot habe ich nicht.
Nur bei Belastung leichter,
aber nicht so ausgeprägt.
Aber wenn Sie
auf der Hals oder unter Arm gespürt, wenn sie oder gesehen eigentlich ich habe
es nicht getastet. Das sie mal alles schicken. Gibt es Probleme beim Schlucken?
Etwas Schluck beschweren habe ich auch. Gute Frage. Vielleicht haben sie
Wurde das Wort brennen auf? In der letzten Zeit etwas auch.
Haben sie Schuhbeschwerden beim Festen oder für sich ein Nahrungsmittag?
Sehr gut. Eigentlich habe ich insgesamt eher bei Festnahrungs leichter, aber es ist auch nicht ausgeprägt.
Ich glaube, wir haben alles gefragt. Kann man noch mehr Fragen stellen?
Es gibt keine Ende. Aber jetzt fangen wir mit dem Arztgespräch an.
Und dann können wir uns im Zwischenruf noch mal Gedanken machen, ob das anders sein könnte.
Okay?
Okay.
Dann.
Noch etwas, eine Frage.
Ich meine, haben Sie Schieds- und Veränderungen im Messer seit Bemerk?
Eigentlich auch nicht.
Okay.
Gute Frage.
Auch nicht. Das ist ein komplizierter Fall. Aber sie kriegen das raus.
Das ist das Beste. Schafft das.
Das ist das Beste. Fangen wir an.
Okay.
Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt.
Haben Sie Kurse seit?
Ja natürlich.
Danke schön.
Heute haben wir einen neuen Patient in unserer Session aufgenommen.
Herr Özdemir ist eine 50-Jährige, der sich wegen seit zwei Monaten verständigt hat.
Die Patiente berichtete, dass Trockenhöchsten mit Belastung zu nehmen werden.
Noch mal der Patient berichtete.
Mit Belastung.
Dass die Beschwerden.
Beschwerde zu nehmen.
Böden.
Unter den belastenden Beschwerden zu nehmen.
Ja, okay.
Letzter Zeit, er sagte, dass die Beschwerde immer schlimmer geworden seien.
Sie berichtete, dass sie Druckgefühl im Bruch.
Sie oder er?
Er.
Ja.
Er hat Druckgefühl im Bruch gefühlt.
Wenn langsam Laufen oder beim Ruhe,
Beschwerde weniger, aber wenn Laufen...
Sie können es so sagen, unter Belastung.
Im Ruhe hat er kein Problem.
So einfach.
Wenn Sie versuchen, die Saat zu kompliziert zu bauen,
dann kommen Sie nicht raus aus dem Thema.
Oder der Husten sei bei Belastung?
Ja, der Husten ist bei Belastung zu nehmen.
Im Ruhe hat er kein Problem.
Der ist symptomfrei.
Kann man auch so sagen.
Okay.
Er berichtete, dass in Laufen,
wenn er ein oder zweimal politische Schleim begleitet sein,
er habe Herzrasen...
Wann hat er Herzrasen während Belastung?
Mit Belastung.
Er hatte keine Schlafstörung.
Aber die Fragen nach Schubteilfrostfebers
erbrochen, verneint.
Erbrechen, ja.
Erbrechen, verneint.
Wie vegetativ eine Mese war,
unerfahlig, bis auf Schubbierennen.
Und...
leicht Schubbischwerden.
Ja.
Schubbischwerden.
Lesterzeit erhabe schileschte apetit aber keine gewichtferen durung
Haber und sie fühle Lesterzeit durft bemäkt
starrt er, starrt er durft bemäkt
und
Unforherkranken kann es in Zimtlatt, Patient, Patient
keine krankheit bekannt
Apunzu, Schmerzmittel,
Annämen, Gaggen, Kinie Schmerz,
Oda Ba Schmerz, aber Apunzu.
Apunzu nimmt ihr als Schmerzmittel.
Können Sie das anders auch formulieren.
Apunzu nimmt ihr Schmerzmittel bei Bedarf,
aber er leidet unter keine chronische Erkrankungen.
Er leidet unter keine chronische Erkrankungen und
er will keine Allergen und
Er hat keine Kinder und seine Brüder sei gesund.
Er ist mit 20 Zigaretten, seit 20 Jahren. Aber er ist seit zwei Monaten weniger. Er ist mit 20 Zigaretten protakt.
Er trinkt ein Bier und macht mal Wohinen. Er mit freundlichen Schnapsen Wein.
Er nimmt keine Drogen. Er sei angestellt von einem Transportfirma und habe keine Füchthaltigkeit.
Er ist mit 20 Zigaretten, seit 20 Jahren.
Er ist mit 20 Zigaretten, seit 20 Jahren. Er trinkt ein Bier und macht jetzt mal Wohinen. Er ist mit 20 Zigaretten, seit 20 Jahren.
Okay, Laryngkastionum hat dann so eine Heiserkeit, ja, so eine Stimmverbandänderung.
Das passt nicht genau, aber natürlich könnte es schon sein.
Es ist nicht atopisch, aber nicht ganz auch topisch muss man sagen.
Was könnte noch sein?
Man kann sich nicht genau ausschließen, aber man muss sich mit einem symptomkonzentrierten Diagnose überlegen.
Man muss mit Husten, Druck auf den Brust, leicht Schluckschwerden sortbrennen.
Was dann sein könnte.
Genau, richtig. Das könnte auch schon sein, warum?
Es kann sein, warum?
Sie erhabe, sortbrennen, schluckschwerden und tröcken Husten, die Irritation hier.
Genau, richtig. Das könnte auch sein.
Was noch?
Es kann sein, warum?
Ja, aber Fahrengslagen, wenn man die alles nimmt, die passen nicht genau.
Das ist nicht so typisch, Fahrengslagen.
Es ist dann am Ende der Desserts, dass die Fahrengslagen kommen.
Am Anfang ist das dann der Speiseröhrer, so Fahrengs,
von Grundschial, könnte es schon sein.
Medisinaltumor ist auch nicht ganz typisch, aber könnte trotzdem sein,
weil die Symptomen nicht dazu passen.
Und was halten Sie? Wie können Sie dann weitergehen, wenn Sie so was verdacht haben?
Sie haben so eine Pastin, was würden Sie als erstes machen?
So weiter in der Kuloren empfehle ich die Folgen der Masthenamen.
Erstens natürlich körperliche Untersuchungen.
Wir gucken Ihre Mund und vielleicht mit Spaten, mit Fahrengs.
Sie können sagen, Kompals untersuchen.
Wir gucken nicht nur zum Hals, sondern auch zum Kopfbereich auf dem Hals.
Läuft das Hals und kann dann als Schild bereichen.
Wir können eine Expression mit Lungen anschauen.
Sie machen eine Lungen-Untersuchung?
Ja, Auskultation, Perkussion.
Und natürlich ein Brutbild.
Sind wir mit dem Körper-Untersuchungen schon fertig?
Oder machen Sie noch weiter was?
Wir können vielleicht ein Schilders-Interventionen...
Ja, aber da brauchen Sie Unterschiede.
Das waren Sie dann hefstkardial, auch den auch machen.
Nicht vergessen, der Staat gehört dazu.
Dann machen Sie noch weiter was?
Und nach dem körperlichen Untersuchungen, Labor Diagnostik, großes Brutbild
und Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Kardiak-Enzyme.
Und EKG, Elektro-Kardiografie natürlich?
Ja, kardiak-Enzyme würde ich das nicht unbedingt machen lassen,
solange ich nicht sicher bin, warum ich das machen soll.
Weil jede Untersuchung, was sie veranlassen,
falls die auffällig sind, aber die nicht relevant sind,
zu einer Mlaser, dann können schon Probleme machen.
Hier, bei Sinn hat es nicht so ein typisches kardial Problem,
der hat etwas anders und der ist es als Nebenbeschwerden.
Daher will ich mich auf den Hauptproblemen konzentrieren.
Durch die Belastung des Blöds, durch den Schluckbeschwerden,
will ich etwas anders machen.
Bronkoskopie und Gastroskopie, vielleicht.
Gastroskopie ist ein Phagoskopie.
Genau, das ist das alte Standard.
Wegen Schluckbeschwerden will ich das als erstes
in Stadipunktoskopie erstmal eine.
Das Suskopie machen wir vor allem,
würde ich an der Rücken fahren lassen.
Das ist der einfachste, dass man an der Rücken fahren lasst
und guckt, wenn sie nach Tumor sagen,
wenn sie gucken, wie das aussieht, sieht man in der Rücken
schon was Auffälliges, die man achten soll.
Falls eine große Tumor in der Lunge ist,
dann brauchen sie nicht so fast zu Gastroskopien,
dann machen sie Brunschdiskopie.
Aber nach Kaya natürlich.
Sie haben das gemacht,
Sie haben nicht so großes Auffällig gesehen.
Dann haben Sie jetzt Gastroskopie durchgeführt
und dort haben Sie in den Phagosbereich
einen großen Herde gesehen.
Wie geht es weiter denn?
Und dann City, Torax und Emeryke,
und Hassbereich.
City, Torax und Hass, Emeryke von wo?
City, Torax ist richtig.
City, Torax und Emeryke, Hassbereich.
Hass, Emeryke, man kann man machen.
Es ist nicht verkehrt, aber bei City, Torax, City geht immer schneller.
Sie machen City, Torax und immer hier macht man am meisten abdominal.
Toracal macht man fast nie.
Bei Kufhalstummen macht man nur,
wenn man den Kufhalstummen verdacht hat,
das ist was anderes.
Aber dort ist auch City am meisten ausreichend.
Manchmal verbrochen auch die Gwebeunterschiede,
genau so sehen, denn die Grinsen von die Gwebe,
aber von den Akuten, oder von der Erste,
die ist das Beste, weil es das schnell geht,
dann können Sie schon was sehen.
Was Sie nicht im City sehen,
im Hals oder Lungen, wenn Sie im RT sowieso nicht sehen,
das ist schon klar.
Aber im Bau abdominal City, dann ist es was anderes.
Dann kann man was anderes überlegen,
um den RT zu veranlassen, aber hier kommt nicht
im Frage unbedingt.
Natürlich kann man es machen, wenn man sagt,
ich würde das eine prätonialer Geschichte noch dazu
genau sehen, dann kann man den RT veranlassen,
weil der RT, mit der RT sieht man den prätonial besser als CT.
Aber muss man nicht unbedingt, wie Sie gesagt haben,
CT-Hals-Torax, reicht das aus, weil Probleme liegt hier oben.
Wenn Sie oben was verdacht haben,
dann müssen Sie erstmal oben schauen,
wenn Sie später das unbedingt weiter ausschließen,
dann können Sie auch immer die machen.
Sie sind ein richtiger Weg, ja, CT-Hals-Torax.
Und weiter?
Und vielleicht Spirometrie.
Spirometrie, genau, das ist auch richtig.
Warum? Sie wollen auch den Atemweg mal den Lungenstatus mal genau sehen.
Wie schwer ist der Lungen damit belastet?
Hat er Richten und hat er Richten problematisch
mit der Lungenfunktion, der seine Lungenfunktion testen zu lassen?
Auch wenn Sie später was anderes machen.
Das ist ganz toll, ja.
Und noch?
Und noch wenn Brunkoskopie und Gastrosophagoskopie,
wenn wir sehen...
Aber Sie haben jetzt eine Gastroskopie gemacht, ja.
Dort haben Sie die Tumme gesehen.
Dann haben Sie eine CT gemacht.
Im CT sehen Sie trotzdem sowieso,
ob Sie in den Lungen was haben oder nicht.
Das dann mussten Sie nicht unbedingt in der Brunkoskopie fahren lassen.
Machen Sie nur erst, wenn Sie sagen,
ich vermute schon, dass in Brunkial was so sein könnte.
Was ich im CT nicht genau sehe, dann können Sie es machen.
Oder wenn Sie sagen, die Tumme druck auf den Weg,
durch die Speiserer drin rein, dann können Sie es machen.
Ansonsten müssen Sie nicht.
Und wenn wir in der Kopie,
wenn wir sagen, die pathologische Bereiche,
die Biopsy abnehmen können.
Genau, wenn Sie mit der Indeskopie reingegangen sind,
Sie haben das auch gesehen,
Sie werden in der Kopie eine Biopsy entnehmen.
Das heißt, Sie nehmen eine Biopsy aus dieser Stelle raus
und schicken sie ins Pathologie.
Einfach eine historische Sicherung zu haben
und die Art von Tummus genau zu wissen, was es ist.
Und wie muss man natürlich gucken,
manchmal Häsrasen haben?
Das passt natürlich genau richtig.
In der Mitte können Sie es auch machen,
können Sie auch Langsinnigungen machen,
weil während Belastung ist noch mehr.
Metastassozio hat den Kollegen geschrieben,
natürlich ist es auch, wir haben ja das gemacht,
wir haben CTTorax, der hat es gemacht.
Und am meisten, wenn wir vermuten,
dass die Tumme am CTTorax, wenn man sagt,
je nachdem, wie der CTTorax beschrieben wird,
sagt man seine Tumme in der Speiseröhre
oder so, fahres Tumme mit T2 oder T3
so hoch sitzen die Metastasieren nicht im Bauchbereich.
Dann braucht man nicht unbedingt
eine abdominale CTTor der Mathe zu veranlassen.
Wenn sagt, das ist eine T4
und man sieht noch Lymphknoten im Hals
und Lymphknoten im Aksilärbereich oder Toracal,
dann kann man eine komplette CT
von oben bis unterdurch führen,
das CTTorax und Abdomen, um genau zu sehen.
Dann haben Sie recht.
Aber je nach Sintigraphie muss man nicht in diesem Fall,
weil den Speiseröhretomor an die Metastasieren
nicht unbedingt in den Knochen.
Daher bei Mamekastionum genau richtig, ja.
Bei Lungenkastionum, wenn Sie korrativ
patient haben, machen Sie das auch.
Da macht man's pizzi, denn sieht man sowieso,
ja, aber muss man sich nicht unbedingt sind,
aber dann macht man auch.
Aber Prost hat er auch, aber wir machen das fast nie.
Ich habe bisher nie gesehen,
dass man zu einer Knochenmetastase drückt,
aber vorgeschritten schon, wenn die Stadopier sind,
die haben wir meistens schon,
aber es ist der Stadium 1, 2, die haben fast sowieso,
die haben keine lokaler vorgeschrittenen Kranken,
dass die noch Fernmetastasierung haben.
Tumomaker, ja genau, was wollen wir machen, Tumomaker?
Dann sollen Sie das jetzt genau sagen,
was werden Sie machen?
Dr. Aicha hat geschrieben,
Sie soll das beantworten.
Sie fragen, wer ist der Tumomaker?
Ja, ja, was braucht man da hier?
Gibt es eine spezielle Tumomaker
von der Speisererkrankung, der Kletch?
Spezielle Tumomaker.
Ja, genau, aber ganz GI Tumomaker, die sind nicht hier speziell.
Und daher, auch wenn Sie das nicht machen,
sind Sie auch nicht verkehrt.
Wir machen fast nie, weil wir brauchen es halt nicht.
Wenn Sie in der Laststadion sind,
dann ist es schon hart wert,
dann brauchen wir nicht.
Rücken wie Fund, nach Rücken wie Fund,
wie gesagt, nach CT-Trocks,
CT-Trocks, wenn wir das haben.
Rücken haben wir auch in der Notaufnahme gemacht.
Falls wir nichts zu viel gesehen haben,
dann machen wir CT-Trocks,
dann brauchen wir auch keine neuem Rücken.
Ich glaube, das war die Frage, ob wir das machen oder nicht.
Ich weiß nicht genau.
Okay, dann ich glaube, wir haben alles durch jetzt.
Wir haben eine ober-sitzende Speiserer-Trebs,
die so einen trocken husteln,
weil durch die Reisen und leicht die Stranose,
man verschluckt sich,
oder sagen wir es sich, der Speiserer oben,
und dann ist es so eine Hustenverursacht auch.
Aber trotzdem muss man nicht vergessen,
es könnte auch in der Lungenkrebs sein,
wenn man die Neem-Symptomatik nicht hat,
zum Beispiel diese Schluckbeschwerden.
Bei ausgebreitem Schluckbeschwerden hat man richtig Schleim.
Das ist schon was anderes.
Wenn man die Flüssigkeit runterstücken könnte,
da ist es gar keine Hustenverursacht.
Und daher, Sie haben es gut differenziert,
aber Sie sollen es genau nochmal,
wie ich es mal gesagt habe,
Sie sollen sich auf dem Symptom konzentrieren
und nicht so viel in die Ecke reingehen.
Und dann verlieren Sie den Konzentration,
es mehr oder weniger.
Versuchen Sie einfach Satz zu bauen,
statt komplizierter Satz zu bauen.
Damit können Sie Ihre Konzentration gut kontrollieren.
Sie sind sowieso der Fachmann, Konzentration-Fachmann.